vous êtes 7 millions d'abonnés à ma
chaîne youtube merci
c'est donc l'heure de répondre à vos
questions et là dedans
est ce que tu pourrais nous montrer ton
appartement
voilà à 60 ans t'imagines pu faire
encore des vidéos
bah pourquoi pas tant que je peux créer
des trucs sur internet le plus longtemps
possible ça me plait parents je pense
que ce sera des vidéos assez différente
de celle ci un mec continue ans je suis
posté remarqué mais quand tu portes pas
de couches et que home et le ton fils
s'appelle sipri 2 comment as tu réagi
quand tu as appris qu'il y avait cet
fumeurs de ta mort dans un accident de
voiture
mais c'est moi triste et champagne
champagne intégrer oui enfin on doit
toujours tu as quel âge j'ai 24 ans et
c'est plutôt bizarre de répondre à la
question d'un cheval il te reste une
heure à vivre ce que paie tu es d'accord
je vais sur un site de cudos maintenant
je vais voir ma famille
alors je fais une bonne action et
ensuite tu arrives à lécher son coude ou
thé omoplates
bien sûr combien de temps mais tue
environ pour préparer une vidéo alors ça
dépend en tout cas le plus long c'est
l'écriture peut prendre des semaines
pour que j'écrive une vidéo qui me
plaisent ou après le tournage et le
montage c'est la sphère de bulles
quelques jours voilà tu es pas mort si
tu serais un pokémon qui serait lequel
alors il ya clairement un que j'adore
après des années de travail d'une équipe
composée des plus grands artistes je
connais aussi le pokémon au plus élaboré
le plus charismatique depuis la création
du jour je parle de vie d'amande ou
métamorphe times si oui à quoi il
ressemble alors oui s'appelle jessica et
voici une photo de nous deux voilà y at
il des jours où tu te dis que tu
aimerais faire autre chose que des
vidéos alors c'est très intéressant
comme question parce que j'ai un petit
peu réfléchi et en fait la réponse est
assez évidente ya rien de plus
épanouissant que de faire des vidéos
pour moi aujourd'hui dans toute ma vie
c'est ce que je préfère faire voilà mais
de tous à part baiser bien évidemment
jessica quel est ton film préféré
bonne question très compliquée ce jeune
talent film
fish d'acquérir un jurassic park star
wars
je pense que le film qui m'a fait le
plus qui fait dans toute ma vie c'est
dommage est ce que tu as déjà eu un
manque d'inspiration alors oui parfois
tu sais pas trop quoi raconter et le
mieux dans ces cas là c'est de ne rien
dire un essai quand tu ne cherches pas
l'inspiration qu'elle vient le plus
souvent donc à la fois prendra à gérer
ça et surtout à raconter des histoires
tout a vraiment envie de raconter à tes
déjà signé des autographes
non pour une raison très simple c'est
que je ne sais pas écrire comment tu te
sens quand tu regardes une de tes
anciennes vidéos comme ça pourquoi tu
t'es moins deux vidéos qu'avant alors
j'ai eu plusieurs fois cette question ça
m'a pas mal intrigué et comme je suis un
grand journaliste d'investigation j'ai
réalisé cette petite cerise de mes
vidéos depuis plus d'un an et je ne
pense pas faire de moins en moins une
vidéo en sorte qu'un autant surtout se
rajoutent les bêtisiers et mes vidéos
cycle un gaming si vous aimez les jeux
vidéo en tout cas si vous pensez ça ça
veut dire que vous en voulez plus donc
ça me fait plaisir
voudrais tu faire du mal google
quidditch alors celle de quidditch c'est
le sport dans harry potter que j'ai lu
tous les livres et ça c'est la version
avec des vrais joueurs
j'ai vu des vidéos sur internet
ce qu'on va faire c'est qu'on va arrêter
la drogue tout de suite
ceci était un communiqué du ministère de
la santé tu penses toujours pechoux
après ça alors
alors en vrai je vous ai menti voilà je
suis pas en couple avec jessica ça aux
étonné mais c'était un photomontage en
réalité et on voit je suis en couple
avec patricia tu vas appelé cyprien
répond ouais réponse jeudi
ta réaction qu'on a eu 5 millions
d'abonnés
wattez maison tu fais moins brouillée ok
oui patricia voilà ce qu'en fait j'ai
cinq minutes de jeu est ce que tes
vidéos sont vraies absolument le mariage
homosexuel de ma cousine
vol de mon ordinateur tout ça est vrai
comment tu as rencontré squeeze alors
c'est une histoire assez banal
ah excusez moi c'est ce panaf saoudite
créer une chaîne youtube avec moi mais
oui mais bercy
voilà c'est tout pour aujourd'hui
malheureusement j'ai pas pu répondre à
tous puisque vous m'avez posé en tout 25
mille questions
on y maurice tu préfères kev adams ou
gad elmaleh non je préfère gad elmaleh
parce que moi aussi je rêve d'une banque
top